saying prayers is the only thing at man
been Amara can do now for his late son
Madhava is buried here along with other
victims of a January attack on a
military academy in Tripoli 32 cadets
were killed in the air strike launch it
by forces loyal to the warlord Khalifa
Haftar Earthman says his son who had
just turned 19 before the attack had an
ambition to become a pilot and had many
hobbies including horse riding my
family's life has become so difficult
we've lost happiness and interest in
life after we lost her son we will not
rest until Hefner and his backers are
brought to international justice one
year since after launching his military
campaign to take control of Tripoli from
the UN recognized government his
offensive has failed to achieve its
goals international mediation has failed
to in the conflict including a recent
call on the warring parties to embrace a
truce to allow the country to tackle
kovat 19 many parts of southern Tripoli
have been deserted and more than 150,000
people have been displaced by the
fighting the United Nations estimates
Hefner's forces have launched it more
than a thousand airstrikes since the
beginning of their offensive last year
residential areas and state facilities
have been targeted along with airports
and migrant detention centers Tripoli's
UN recognized the government blames
Egypt and the United Arab Emirates which
support after for the hundreds of
civilian deaths more than a dozen
medical workers have been killed in
drone attacks on field hospitals and in
July fifty-three migrants were killed by
air strikes the Tripoli based government
accuses Egyptian
you a warplanes of carrying out the
attacks if half this forces advanced
more inside residential areas war crimes
and crimes against humanity will be
committed by his multinational
mercenaries Libyans cannot stop this war
but the regional and international
players can Hefner is also supported by
Russia and politically by France while
the internationally recognized the
government in Tripoli has military
support from Turkey as this conflict
goes on there is a sense those
responsible for killing civilians won't
be held to account
victims families like earth man are
likely to wait for a long time to get
justice if they get it at all
Mahmoud Abdul Wahid al jazeera Tripoli